thank you so much for joining us we
begin tonight right here in new york
city
where we see cops being shot on a daily
basis
crime is rising the subways are no
longer safe
assaults are a commonplace
on your screen you're looking at just a
few of the recent examples of this
violence
the scenes are difficult to watch and
far too often involve
innocent bystanders
and with that
i wanted to know what the people of new
york city are feeling so today i went
out on the streets just to find out
watch
do you feel safe in the city
yeah absolutely i think it's a day like
today it's great to be walking around
and be around all these people outside i
don't feel unsafe walking around or
doing anything absolutely i think um
why i trust the the police force a lot
and i think that their the city is back
and rejuvenated and so there are people
out all the time and yeah i feel safe do
you feel safe in the city yeah
i do well
i've not had any experience with crime i
think new york city is fairly safe and i
i just don't walk around being afraid
it's always light sun there's police all
over yeah i love new york as a young
woman i definitely always have to think
about my surroundings i'm not like
walking around scared all the time but i
think
it's always a thought like oh it's 11
o'clock maybe i should take
a certain way home these incidents are
serious
but i feel safe if you're out during the
day and not roaming around in the middle
of the night maybe i might not feel as
safe but i do feel safe i feel safe
walking on the street um
i've been here 12 years i think overall
i feel safe yeah currently yeah i mean
i'm with my friends i'm with people that
make me feel safe so i mean as long as
i'm not alone i feel safe so in new york
yes i do feel very
safe but i might not have the right
perspective because i wasn't here when
it was really bad in new york
when it was really bad now wait just a
minute
just so we are clear
in spite of these cold hard facts on
your screen look at the numbers
overwhelm overall crime transit crime
shooting incidents
they feel like it's okay
i learned today that all of this is
being accepted
it's almost as if it's being normalized
i left that park beyond stunned frankly
i didn't expect those responses
but i wasn't the only one
the former cops who were there
to give me protection that day
we're left speechless
one even said this is why he retired
especially when he heard this
like i said man happens people people
always try to save each other but like
sometimes they deserve it um but
i understand they're trying to protect
us they're doing the best they can but
like
to an extent all cops are faster it's
you know
[Music]
it like like that that's all i really
gotta say i think it's important to
defund the police and invest more in our
communities and that's what will
actually impact what's happening
um and i don't feel unsafe walking
around
there's been five officers that have
been shot
in the last month two of them were
tragically killed what do you think
about what is driving that
um i don't know it's driving it i think
it's like terrible that they lost their
lives but i don't think that the two are
necessarily related
with everything that's going on they
still want to defund the police and just
so we're clear
all those conversations that we were
having
that was everyone there was everyone i
couldn't find anyone that said that
crime was about
was high right now hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else